et
souvent les gens que l'on voit dans la
vraie vie savent qu'ils m'ont vu quelque
part mais savent plus trop où
au resto le petit bouffon d'internet là
comme je tapais déjà moi c'est cyprien
non toujours est-ce que ton charente et
vidéo est un vrai show man comme et dire
j'ai pris des métiers nul je fais un
métier je passe connaissez un métier où
t'es pas rémunérés et on se prend pour
une merde ça s'appelle un stage pour
donner un peu mon poste dans
l'entreprise j'avais un badge de
stagiaires avec écrit dessus le nom de
l'ancien stagiaire
j'ai passé six mois à me faire appeler
sabrina
il est su de tous
marqué par une soirée hip hop avec un
pote soirée cauchemardesque
j'en arrive devant la boîte hip hop le
vigile attendez les gars vous êtes 2
sera accompagné par théo revenez quatre
filles peut-être que vous rentrerez
fêteront les faire à toi mec pas et on
trouve quatre filles on revient pas
merci à tous